the barbarians who were tearing down our
nation's statues and history and entire
culture over the past few weeks have
pretended that they are doing it sparked
by the officer-involved killing of
George Floyd that's been the line
they've been saying say their names
that's being one of the slogans of the
entire rioting however the national
political leaders of this rioting Chuck
Schumer Nancy Pelosi when pressed on it
can't actually remember the name of the
guy they're saying say their name to
prompt all of the rioting for the
families of Floyd Taylor a George Taylor
I only will do that if you tell me that
this legislation is worthy of George
Kirby's name worthy of George Kirby's
name george kirby by the way was an
American comedian from the 1960s and 70s
and also a convicted drug dealer he got
pinched by the cops for dealing coke and
heroin in the 70s and then later went
into schools and told everyone not to do
drugs and that's sort of beside the
point
Nancy Pelosi doesn't know George Floyd's
name and neither does Chuck Schumer but
of course they don't remember the name
because it was never about George Floyd
what is happening
still today around the country is an
ideological attack on our country on our
culture and on our civilization we
should all say their names all of the
names we should say the names of the
victims of police brutality the names of
the victims of mob brutality and most
importantly of all is probably the least
popular group to say their names we
should say the names of the people whose
statues are being toppled down the
people who built this country
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the left does not want to say their
names we'll get to why just one second
first though I got to thank our friends
over at ring you know that these days
it's good to protect yourself against
people who want to steal your packages
and shipments we are home a lot more
than usual these days and every day we
don't know we're gonna stay home we're
gonna go to the office we're gonna be
able to go at it sorry to keep an eye on
things hard to hard to get into a
routine ring is on a mission to make
neighborhoods safer their home security
products are designed to give you peace
of mind around the clock from video
doorbells and security cameras to smart
security lighting and alarm systems ring
has everything you need to make sure
that your family and belongings are safe
and secure anytime anywhere and with the
all new ring video doorbell three you
can keep an even closer eye on things
than ever before I really love ring I
trust these guys I trust them so much
that I give out ring as a housewarming
present to my friends part of the reason
I do this is because it's so cool you
can check out and check on your home
when you're in the office or on a beach
the other reason is it's fairly
inexpensive so that you get a lot of
good credit for giving it to your
friends and you don't have to spend too
much money you can get a special offer
on the ring welcome kit when you go to
ring.com slash an old Skinner WLA s and
welcome kit includes ring video doorbell
three chime pro all you need to start
building custom security for your home
today go to ring.com slash knowles
what's that address ring comm slash
knowles
the left does not want to say their
names they say they want to say their
names but they don't want to say their
names they want to erase their names
they want to erase specific names and
specific people with general
abstractions that's what you see all the
time in the cases of allegations of
police brutality if the alleged police
brutality doesn't even turn out to be
true doesn't matter what do they say
they say well forget about that specific
instance just talk about the larger
truth even if they don't have any
specific instances to build up to their
larger truth and when we're talking
about specific cases like the killing of
George Floyd they pretend it's about
George Floyd but it's not really it's
about this general ideological idea
completely disconnected from facts this
has no logical end to it there's no Lynn
limiting principle rather progressives
are now willing to erase the names even
of the most famously progressive
president in US history which one am I
talking about I'm talking about Woodrow
Wilson Princeton University has a had I
should say a school of public affairs
and international relations that was
named after Woodrow Wilson had until
about three days ago when they renamed
the school I cannot believe that I am
defending Woodrow Wilson sword I'm not
really defending him Woodrow Wilson is
one of the worst presidents in American
history but that's not why he's being
canceled he's being canceled because not
not because of the League of Nations not
because he totally undermined American
government not not because he screwed up
international relations for a century
it's because of another one of his flaws
which is that he was very very racist
and you know he screened movies like
Birth of a Nation in the White House and
so now they're canceling him I'm very
torn how am I supposed to feel about
this I don't like when we topple statues
and erase people from history and we
rename buildings because of changing
social mores I also don't like Woodrow
Wilson I think he's one of the worst
presidents in American history even
conservatives should oppose this kind of
thing even conservatives should defend
Woodrow Wilson who is probably the least
conservative president we've ever had
Carter and Obama I guess are up there
too but Wilson really much much worse
because of has significant he was when I
mentioned that it's probably a dumb idea
to rename Woodrow Wilson's school there
was a conservative blogger who took
issue with me and he said look it's it's
good to lose Wilson Wilson was a bad
president do you agree do you think
Wilson was a good good guy or a bad guy
at which I think kind of misses the
point and in a way he was kind of making
my point and then he said look at a time
where we're so at each other's throats I
think it's just good that we can all
come together and dislike Woodrow Wilson
and this is the problem okay this is
what this is the trap that some
conservatives are falling into and we're
only going to realize that we've fallen
to it I think once our entire culture is
gone yes Woodrow Wilson is a president
that conservatives don't like but when
we tear down his statues when we rename
schools that are named after him we buy
into the left's premises that we need to
constantly be toppling statues and
liberating ourselves from the oppressive
past and looking down on those bad
people in the in the past those bad
ancestors looking on the tradition in
the past with such ingratitude that we
rip down their names when we buy into
that leftist premise of toppling statues
then any victory we might have over
Woodrow Wilson who cares is a Pyrrhic
victory it's a victory in which we
actually lose because we've bought into
the premise of our adversaries and
there's no end to that at all fine okay
it's fine that they're gonna Woodrow
Wilson's a bad guy in a Democrat I've
been saying that for years but for
instance what this one conservative
blogger said to me is that I'm fine with
something not being named after Wilson
yeah me too
but that's not the question the school
is already named after Wilson the
question is are we gonna rename things
and pull down statues and if you if you
given us what I've been saying all week
on the Lee thing on General Lee when you
give in on Lee you've given in on
Lincoln and you've given in on st.
Junipero Serra and you've given in a
Jesus wish now that's how quickly we've
escalated into the attacks on statues is
now they're talking about smashing
windows of Jesus and very few people
have had the cojones to defend any of
these figures but speaking of Jesus
there was one priest over the weekend in
st. Louis even st. Louis in another st.
has come under attack and the mob wants
to rename the city of st. Louis and tear
down the st. louis statue so this priest
decided to show up great young priest
and give everyone a history lesson take
a listen
he didn't do anything to earn it you're
right he didn't do an Internet what did
he do with that authority you know what
he did Louis was a man who willed to use
his kingship to do good for his people
that's not possible
[Music]
so then shall he was bad against
Africans because he went to chooser
but the Arabs lived in Tunisia the Arabs
had taken over Tunisia by that century
they can't take that back today I don't
want to hear anything about that face so
you have this great priest who's a young
guy I don't know what is he in his 20s
and he shows up and he just gives these
people a history lesson and he says what
are you you're angry at st. Louie
because of what because because he was
bad to Africans what do you he wasn't
Africans had nothing to do with the
reign of st. Louie oh well he he went
into Tunisia
well Tunisia was run by Arabs Arabs who
had invaded Tunisia and we're not
particularly nice to the Africans who
were there and sold thousands and
thousands of them into slavery it
doesn't matter that this is what happens
by the way when you take out any kind of
historical education from schools
I mean you right now Western European
history is basically not taught even
when I was in school which you know I
graduated high school in 2008 even then
European history was not taught it was
an AP elective if you wanted to take it
but this is what happens people don't
know anything about their own culture
st. Louis was a saint
his mother famously said I had rather
see
you dead at my feet then guilty of a
mortal sin he was very good to his
people he was a very just King and here
you see a little bit of this abstract
ideology of liberalism is they don't
know anything about st. Louis but they
know that according to liberalism we
always have to be liberating ourselves
from the oppressive past any King must
be terrible any democracy must be
wonderful anything in the olden days
must be bad anything now must be good
though I think with all the rioting and
the statue toppling in the madness a lot
of people I wouldn't mind living under
the st. Louis right now compared to some
of the woke mob that's now taken over
our country so what is going to happen
about this finally finally the president
has signed an executive order to protect
the statues is it too little too later
is it gonna do something I think
actually it's already turning out pretty
well we'll get to that one second first
though I've got to thank our friends
over at blink sail have you ever had to
chase down a client for company that
owed you money for your work maybe
you're stuck in the dinosaur age of
creating invoices in Microsoft Word I
mean you might as well be edging them
onto a stone tablet having to manually
track and organize all of them in your
files just stop it
stop it man it's 2020 if we're gonna
have to deal with all the chaos of 2020
at least enjoy some of the benefits okay
you should not have to waste time
creating ugly invoices in some word
processor and you shouldn't have to send
nagging emails to get your invoices paid
and you shouldn't have to worry about
getting paid period use blink sale with
blink sale you can send beautiful custom
branded invoices and estimates in
seconds and you can stay on top of your
outstanding invoices and even let your
customers and clients pay your invoices
online you get instant notifications
it's just so easy it's terrific
see for yourself try blink sale for free
right now at blink sale comm slash
Noel's canna wles that is bli NK s al e
dot com slash Knowles blink sales spend
less time billing and more time doing
what you love so president Trump to sign
this executive order to protect statues
the executive order in the 30,000 foot
view prohibits desecration of public
monuments and vandalism on government
property and
all of the recent acts of violence that
we've been seeing everywhere crucially
it withholds federal money and funding
that is tied to public spaces from state
and local governments that fail to
protect the public monuments so if the
if the local government we talked about
this when we sat down with attorney
general bill bar last week he said that
the trouble here is the federal
government can't be everywhere at all
times nor would we really want it to be
so you've got to rely on state and local
governments to protect these places and
if they're not going to do it then we're
in a little bit of a bind well one thing
we can do is withhold money from them
it also withdraws federal grants for
jurisdictions and law enforcement
agencies that fail to stop their
desecration so another thing that's been
driving us crazy is you see people
tearing down these statues it's
obviously very organized and we'll get
to hat just how organized this movement
is in a moment and you say where are the
cops now I get it the cops are between a
rock and a hard place because if they
don't do their jobs I'm gonna criticize
them and if they do do their jobs they
might they might get charged with murder
or something right i mean they're
they're obviously very unpopular right
now they don't have any political
support so i I sympathize with the cops
here but if law enforcement is not going
to stop the rioting then and not gonna
stop the desecration then they're gonna
lose their funding and really that's
just a political problem for state and
local to figure out so I'm glad
President Trump did this actually he did
something over the weekend though that I
like even more he tweeted out the images
of people who have not been caught they
are fugitive criminals who have torn
down public property and our history and
our culture he tweeted at their photos
and he said we're looking for this
person if you can identify them let us
know because we're going to arrest them
and prosecute them and throw them in
prison for 10 years love this mmm I love
it's as though he listens to this show
maybe other people have been saying it
too but I certainly have which is that
conservatives need to buck up and use
the institutional power we have what
little institutional power we have to
actually affect our political ends one
of which is save the statues save our
culture well how can we do that local
law enforcement has its hands tied
behind its back
the local and state governments aren't
going to help at all the administrative
state doesn't particularly want to do
anything as I said the only thing we
really have at our disposal is the bully
pulpit talk radio and Trump's Twitter
account and we can talk til we're blue
in the face well one way to use those
things is to put their photos up there
on Trump's Twitter account which
everybody is paying attention to some
conservatives I think some of the more
squishy types they don't like this they
say oh it's too personal it's too Trump
is getting too down in the muck he
should not be the one yes he should
Trump is the actual chief law
enforcement officer in the country we
refer to the Attorney General that way
but who's the Attorney General's boss in
the executive it's the president Trump
absolutely should be doing this I love
it I think this kind of thing is exactly
what we elected him for this is the
right idea and the press is furious
because now that he's finally fighting
back after weeks I think he should have
done earlier but now he's finally
fighting back the left is starting to
pivot they're pivoting back to corona
corona virus and they're pivoting back
to Russia gate seriously they're
pivoting back to Russia
the New York Times over the weekend
published this piece alleging that
Russia quote secretly offered bounties
to Taliban linked militants for killing
coalition forces in Afghanistan now that
I don't know whether or not that
allegation is true that on its own is
not a news story Russia is an adversary
of the United States so I wouldn't be
surprised if they tried to get our
troops when they're in Afghanistan as
you'll recall in the 1980s we spent a
good good time trying to get their
troops when they were in Afghanistan so
this kind of flight goes back a little
bit of a long way here's the issue
the New York Times alleged it Trump knew
about it The Times writes the
intelligence finding was briefed to
President Trump and the White House's
national security council discussed the
problem at an interagency meeting in
late March the officials said so I was
saying Trump knew about this in late
March and he hasn't and the implication
being he hasn't done anything to Russia
yet the implication being he's a stooge
for Russia or he's really weak for
Russia or or Putin's got something on
him right it's the same trash that we've
been hearing for
for years with no evidence whatsoever
and a lot of evidence to the contrary
and the times though they're so
desperate because the statue thing and
the coronavirus thing it didn't work to
completely destroy Trump so they're
going back to their old bag of tricks
and trying to say that that Trump is a
Manchurian Candidate for Russia now the
Director of National Intelligence John
Ratcliffe smacked down this theory said
quote I have confirmed that neither the
president nor the Vice President were
ever briefed on any intelligence alleged
by the New York Times in its reporting
yesterday somebody's lying
either it's the Director of National
Intelligence or it's the New York Times
DNI or NYT my money would be on the New
York Times lying why because the New
York Times keeps getting Russia wrong do
you remember let me take you back three
years over three years to Valentine's
Day 2017 New York Times runs a headline
trump campaign aides had repeated
contacts with russian intelligence they
were running with this this is a big
story they loved this story and then we
got James Comey testifying James Comey
one of their guys big lefty hates Donald
Trump but because Comey was giving
testimony he had to admit that the New
York Times story was not true it was not
true they got it wrong the New York
Times whenever they write about Russia I
don't know why they get it wrong maybe
they've got weak sources maybe they've
got weak journalistic standards I'm not
saying that Russia didn't didn't go
after US troops in Afghanistan that
might have happened but the thing is we
get so much intelligence every day right
there's just a virtually limitless
amount of intelligence that comes in the
president doesn't get briefed on all of
that intelligence and so the claim
that's made here is that the president
got briefed on it no evidence of that
whatsoever terrible track record at the
New York Times and the timing is just so
convenient because as we move on from
one completely manufactured crisis from
another completely manufactured crisis
now we find ourselves in you guessed it
a manufactured crisis so that was the
New York Times attempt your Times tried
to hit him
but obviously there are other hack
papers out there that are trying to take
down this presidents here's another
route this is the one taken by the
Washington Post this one even funnier
flashing a post publishes a piece over
the weekend Trump keeps claiming that
the most dangerous cities in America are
all run by Democrats they aren't they
aren't okay no way well okay let's go to
the graph that is in the very same
article I'll set you up the the blue
graphs the the blue bars are cities run
by Democrats the gray bars are cities
that have a nonpartisan mayor but really
that means left-wing and then the red
bars are the ones run by Republicans can
you see can you see what's going oh so
it looks as though we have one
Republican in Jacksonville Florida then
three of the gray which really means
left-leaning but technically nonpartisan
and then all blue all blue every other
one every other major city blue and the
Washington Post thinks that this proves
their point maybe what they think is
you're just not going to read into the
article maybe what they think is you're
gonna see the headline you're gonna see
you're gonna scroll past it on Facebook
or Twitter or something like that and
that look like it's it's pretty funny
that they would include the graph in
their article this is the kind of thing
we're gonna see for the next four months
and if Trump wins then obviously for the
next four years this is a dishonest
headline this headline is a lie they say
it's not a lie because there's one city
not run by Democrats but obviously the
point he's making may be changes let's
say virtually all cities nearly all
cities the the point he's making is true
the point they're making here is a lie
same thing happened with the New York
Times they lie to you the media lie to
your face and yet now they want us to
believe them
on locking down again for coronavirus or
on some crime the president from
committed Iran why we've got to tear
down the statues the the media our
complicity i watch the movie Richard
Jewell over the weekend is this Clint
Eastwood movie about this hero security
guard who got smeared as being a
murderer and it was so refreshing to
watch the movie because in the movie the
media or the enemy and they are they are
they're they're the ones doing this kind
of thing
the mainstream media the guys who
pretend to be honest and objective when
really they are not so president Trump's
got his work cut out for him and I got
to say sometimes he doesn't help himself
he doesn't you know I love the guy but
sometimes he makes it hard on himself he
tweeted at a clip over the weekend it
was a group of seniors from the villages
in Florida who were protesting against
each other one of one of the guys hated
Trump the other one was driving buying a
golf cart with the Trump flag Trump
tweets that thank you are the great
people of the villages the radical left
do nothing Democrats will fall in the
fall corrupt Joe is shot see you soon
and it included a video which I guess he
didn't listen to because in the video
the people with the Trump flags were
either jokingly or earnestly yelling the
words
white power okay what is going on in
this video do I think that these seniors
who are driving buying the golf carts
and kind of laughing saying white power
do I think that they are members of the
Ku Klux Klan I don't know for sure but I
don't think so I think what actually
happened in this video is they're going
by and they've got a little Trump flag
and then this kind of maniac the
left-wing or a guy says white power and
they're joking they're mocking him the
first person to say white power in the
clip is not the Trump supporter
it's the Democrat and I think they're
mocking him he goes yeah you're all you
guys are for white power and they're
like oh yeah we're for white power oh we
love white power you got us where's your
Klan hood honey that's what I think this
is really about regardless
probably doesn't help President Trump to
tweet this he tweets it at and then
takes the tweet down when I get this is
easy too I've done this myself you
retweet something and when you look on
Twitter the sound is not there so all
you see is people waving the Trump flag
and they're really excited you don't
hear it necessarily and and I I don't
think the Trump heard it some of my
Democratic friends they were they were
saying Trump knew exactly what he was
doing it's a dog whistle he's a white
supremacist he's a Klansmen if that were
true why would he delete the tweet I
don't I don't why it doesn't it doesn't
help him so I think he just didn't I
take him at his word I think it doesn't
help him but this is one bit of evidence
that he he should at least listen to it
before he retweets it you know I'm not
of the opinion that he should run his
tweets through a committee of
professional campaign consultants who
couldn't win win their way out of a
plastic bag you know we just don't know
anything about actually winning
elections I'm not one of these people
who say take the phone away I don't I
don't think I like that he has the phone
I think the phone is largely why he won
the first time but he might take an
extra second or two before retweeting
that because that that's an unforced
error and one does not need to do it no
serious person thinks that Donald Trump
is a white supremacist no one ever said
this guy's been in public life for forty
years and now only when he runs for
president as a Republican does anyone
suggest he's a racist they do it to all
of us so I don't take that seriously
ironically President Trump is one of the
last politicians in America who is
actually fighting for a colorblind
society you hear this all the time when
when Trump was inaugurated he said we
all bleed the same blood of patriots
doesn't matter if you're black or white
or whatever right he is espousing this
colorblind point of view the left is not
actually the California State
Legislature just took language out of
its constitution to say that we won't
discriminate against people on race they
are now openly advocating discriminating
against people on the basis of their
race of course the way the Democrats are
doing it is they want to discriminate
against whites and Asians in favor of
Hispanics and black people but the the
principle is there you've got Trump
saying don't discriminate against people
you've got the left saying and Democrats
explicitly saying we need to
discriminate against
we'll get to that in one second first
though I've got to thank you you guys
have really turned up at my Michael
Noel's show YouTube channel which is
terrific I appreciate it I like that we
beat Andrew Clavin that was very
important to me just personally we're
closing in on a hundred thousand
subscribers so while you're on The Daily
wire YouTube channel which if you're
watching this on youtube you probably
are just go on type in Michael Noel's
youtube channel go there and subscribe
we would really appreciate it we had a
lot of fun stuff out there including a
clip from my recent interview on dan
bungee nose podcast I can go check that
out if you haven't listened to it man I
love Dan bunch you know I think that guy
totally gets it and I got to sit down
with him for a ride I don't know 45
minutes or an hour or something last
Friday so that was a great time go check
that out we got other clips - I was on
Sean Spicer's show the other day and
just lots of breakout stuff so head on
over and also I do before before you
head on out of youtube I do have a
question for the listeners today a lot
of musicians are changing their names
now to be more woke we'll get to that in
a bit
you know Dixie Chicks lady a that kind
of thing what musician or band do you
think will be next to pander to the woke
mob because their name is not woke
enough let me know in the comments
section and if you're not already a
daily Y remember get a reader's pass at
daily wire.com great value for only 3
bucks a month and when you sign up you
get the first month for just 99 cents
you get access to our mobile app
articles ad free you get great important
editorials such as this one by Andrew
Clavin the Biden campaign proposes on
debate moderated by the day nurse Biden
calls Nana you know important
hard-hitting news
head on over daily wire.com slash
subscribe we'll be right back with a lot
more
they smear Trump baselessly is a racist
when Trump is the last politician in
America pushing for anti racism just
about okay the left is not pushing for
anti racism or colorblind administer
they're pushing for a mirror form of
racial bigotry here is here is until
last Thursday what was in the California
State Constitution very simple phrase
the state shall not discriminate against
or grant preferential treatment to any
individual or group on the basis of race
sex color ethnicity or national origin
in the operation of public employment
public housing or public contracting
simple enough you know how the left
always complains about institutional
racism well there you have it no
institutional racism you are not allowed
to discriminate against or grant
preferential treatment to any individual
group on the basis of race until the
Democrats voted to take that out on
Thursday they voted to get rid of that
line they voted on Thursday to create
institutional racism now they won't
admit that that's racism because their
view of racism is that racism only goes
in one direction of course that isn't
true but that's what they want they
don't want anti racism they don't want
colorblindness they want laws and
regulations that disadvantage white
people and Asian people and give
advantage to other racial groups this is
why the the a group of Asian students
sued Harvard just a little while ago
when we talk about institutional racism
or bigotry we're talking about
affirmative action right affirmative
action is is a rate a bit of racial
discrimination but its racial
discrimination in a way that the left
would prefer and so now that is what
they're pushing for let me let me show
you what I mean even in a more practical
term not just in the laws over the
weekend we had pride you know what pride
is well pride is the deadliest of the
seven deadly sins and pride is the queen
of all vices and pride is also now our
national
secular liberal liturgical celebration
that happens every June coronavirus is
SuperDuper deadly it's so SuperDuper
deadly that you can't go to work and you
can't go to church and you can't go to a
trump rally but it's not so SuperDuper
deadly that you can't show up by the
thousands to celebrate pride because
that's what happened you had this was
from Bloomberg News live aerial footage
shows massive crowds rallying to
celebrate pride in Chicago oh that's
great isn't it
thousands and thousands of people had
they're celebrating pride amid the
allegedly deadly pandemic that we've got
to shut down our whole country for we're
shutting down again they're shutting
down bars and restaurants all over the
country now Texas just shut down again
in LA bars just shut down again these
coronavirus is so SuperDuper serious
unless you are rioting unless you are
looting unless you're pulling down
statues of George Washington unless
you're celebrating imaginative sexual
preferences then you're allowed to go
out this is discrimination the the
discrimination is if you are a leftist
if you're if you're doing something that
the left likes you're allowed to do it
and if you're doing something that the
left doesn't like you're not permitted
to do it you're called a grandma killer
and you're you're blamed for a pandemic
same thing happened to New York New
York's official pride march was
relatively quiet this year they said
because of the pandemic but there was
another one the queer liberation march
drew a large crowd demanding an end to
racism and police brutality but it was
like it was that was just a typical
leftist police brutality canard but it
was about like gay stuff too or
something or transgender stuff oozed all
about the sexual revolution stuff it was
presented intersectionally right so a
lot of it you can hear the chants the
chants they were talking about how black
trans lives matter
shut it down
black trans lives matter mostly white
people protesting in favor of all of
this because when actually when black
voters are polled on LGBT issues turns
out they're not particularly progressive
but white white liberals are so this was
presented intersectionally because some
black transgender people men who
identify as women are killed every year
what they what they don't mention is
that they are killed exclusively almost
or actually exclusively by black men but
that doesn't matter to the
intersectional mob here because the the
whole point is just voicing this kind of
resentment at the system as it stands so
that you can tear it down and
coronavirus it doesn't matter about
coronavirus that point corrupt the
coronavirus hype now the corona virus
itself necessarily but the corona virus
hype in the media the Selective hype one
week it's going to kill you all one week
it doesn't matter at all that is all
political that is all about November if
Joe Biden wins on November third expect
fears of coronavirus to dissipate on
November fourth we've got to talk about
this as two separate issues there is the
virus such as it is and then there is
the hype about the virus and
unfortunately I can't tell you very much
about the virus because the media have
been so contradictory and so dishonest
in their coverage of the virus that we
just don't know what to trust they've
been wrong about it from the very
beginning and then they told us they
actually told us public health officials
and the mainstream media mouthpieces
said that it's it's bad to go out and
protest lockdowns but it's good to go
out and protest Republicans and the
police departments they said it will
help stop the spread of kovat if you go
out by the thousands and tear down
statues and protests for BLM which is a
Marxist organization we'll get to that
in a second too but it will it will
exacerbate our own a virus if you go out
and protest the lockdowns so we can't
trust them it has become strictly
political we know that coronavirus is
being used as a political tool by the
left but
this is not hypocritical this is just
plain discrimination and I think
conservatives at a certain point we need
to stop pretending that it's hypocrisy
the left is not being hypocritical
they're actually being honest they're
telling us we want one set of standards
for you guys and another set of
standards for us
that's not hypocrisy it's like that's
just it's I guess you could call it
hierarchical you could call it unfair
you could call it but it they are being
I call it unjust but they are being
honest about it
the premise of affirmative action is
this if you are a member of a privileged
group if you're a racial minority or you
have imaginative sexual preferences or
you're a woman then you will receive
preferential treatment if you are a
member of a non privileged group namely
white straight male guy who thinks
you're a guy or Asians for some reason
they lump the Asians in here this poor
Asian this is look you know many many of
whom are immigrants many of them don't
have very much money they still get
lumped in as a non privileged group then
you will be officially disadvantaged and
I get it I mean I understand the
arguments they're making for it they're
saying to overcome historical wrongs we
need to treat some people better than we
treat other people on the basis of race
or sex or whatever I get that they're
making that argument
those are moral concepts those are even
religious concepts okay pride itself is
an ethical and religious term pride
goeth before destruction and a haughty
spirit before a fall I always thought
the LGBT group they made a little bit of
a PR error embracing pride the deadliest
of the seven deadly sins not you know
it's and I guess this this year we're
doing wrath to wrath gets lumped in
there as well and we're knocking down
the statues but this is why separation
of church and state as we refer to it
has never been true anywhere the state
always has some relation to religion
because the state deals with religious
and ethical and moral questions you
sometimes hear people say we can't
legislate morality
you can only legislate morality all laws
derive from
moral arguments all civil laws we have
derived from the natural law or some
relationship and understanding of the
natural law everything not just abortion
and the definition of marriage and
capital punishment all the way down to
taxes and parking tickets those come
from moral arguments and so the question
is what kind of morality is your state
following what kind of religion is your
state following I think a lot of
especially Christian conservatives have
kind of tried to back away they use
these lines they say politics is
downstream of culture they use that as
an excuse not to actually worry about
politics or they say you can't legislate
morality well of course you can only
legislate morality and what that has
been is a surrender of our politics to a
new religion a new woke religion a rule
it maybe we got to say its name that
religion which we will in in just one
moment consider the the religious
rituals that have come about just in the
last few weeks that the main one being
the mask you know the mask mask which we
were initially told don't wear the masks
the masks are bad the masks aren't gonna
stop coronavirus we have very little
evidence that the masks do anything at
all then we were told the masks will
protect us then we were told the masks
won't protect us but it will protect
other people now we're being told
something in the middle and now
increasingly we're seeing people not
wearing the masks properly but just
having to have them around as a virtue
signal as a sign that we're on the right
side of the ideology well Joe Biden is
just said if he's elected president he
will completely unconstitutionally
mandate masks at the federal level if
you became president tomorrow what would
you do differently regarding the
pandemic and getting these surging cases
now under control I would go back to
making sure that everybody had masks
that you had PPE lined up we have been
making sure we stockpile all the things
that we need that we don't have now the
one thing we do know these masks make a
gigantic difference I would insist that
everybody on public be wearing that mask
and he wants to reopen it would have to
make sure that they walked into a
business that
did you use your federal leverage to
mandate that though yes and you would
you yes I would from an executive
standpoint yes I would so you would in
effect mandate the wearing of matters
that do everything I'm not possible to
make it make it required the people had
to wear masks in public I would do
everything in my possible and I would so
he realizes at the end because Biden's
been around a long time he realized this
wait a second I just said that I would
mandate masks from the federal level but
I probably don't have the constitutional
power to do that so I would do
everything am I possible one thing to
note here is the man still can't form an
English sentence even though there
they're limiting on the campaign his
public appearances
every time he appears it's clear this
guy is not there he is not with it and
and he falls apart even at the end here
but at the broader level what he's
saying isn't true we don't know that the
masks are SuperDuper effective in fact
all the same people were telling us they
weren't effective just a few weeks ago
we don't we know very little about the
masks and we know that Joe Biden himself
when he was giving a speech just a
couple weeks ago he had the mask
dangling from his ear it wasn't on his
mouth so it wasn't preventing the spread
of coronavirus but it wasn't off either
because if it's off then it he's not on
board he's he wore it dangling down from
his ear just to show people that he's on
the right team people do this now when
you're on an airplane I've taken a
couple airplanes in the last few weeks
or when you're in a restaurant or
something you'll see people wearing the
mask below the nose I guess is what I do
as well and you wear it below the nose
because it this is extremely stupid that
this this constantly changing standard
where you have to wear the mask you
don't have to wear the mask
coronavirus is super deadly but go out
and tear down statues and riot for BLM
and and and show up at pride right so
that's not not really based on science
but you have to have it somewhere right
I was on an airplane and I had the mask
I'm not gonna wear a mask on my face for
five hours I'm just not gonna do it
and so I had the mask under my on my
chin right so my mouth and my nose is
completely exposed and then eventually I
said this is stupid so I just take the
mask off and the stewardess walks up to
he says you have to put your mask on so
I put it back on my chin obviously not
doing anything to stop any of my air
coming out she's okay that's good it's
like wearing a Mantia in a church or a
hijab or wearing a yarmulke if you're
Jewish
it's a it is a
quasi religious symbol saying that we
are all on board in the same metaphysics
and the invisible enemy that we're all
fighting so what's the science say well
the science says that the left-wing
policies that they're all saying are
based on science actually have killed
way more people than anything else
Andrew Cuomo governor of New York has
kept being given credit for being a
leader on coronavirus right he's
actually been the worst governor in the
country on coronavirus and his state as
a result got hit the worst he didn't
have enough ventilators then he
overestimated how many ventilators he
would need he didn't need as many
hospital beds as he thought he would
need and he sent sick people into
nursing homes and the the sick people
going into nursing homes were the most
vulnerable population killed more people
than anything else in this virus this is
according to the New York Times Believe
It or Not 43% of coronavirus linked
deaths according to the New York Times
accounted in nursing homes they took
place in nursing homes
The Times compiled a whole debt database
and they report that about 12,000
nursing homes and care centers have been
linked to 282 thousand cases of
coronavirus of those cases 54,000 people
have died to show you something also
about who's being affected by corona
viruses disproportionately very old
frail and sick people but there are
still policies you can put into place
that will protect them the left hasn't
done that the left sent all the sick
people into the nursing homes and that
accounted for a full 43% of the
coronavirus deaths don't let them tell
you that they're the great defenders of
science here and you're a science denier
because you don't want to wear the
stupid mask tell them to fix their
nursing home policies then you'll talk
about wearing this virtue signal masks
speaking of virtue signaling some bands
now are changing their names it's not
just the statues coming down it's the
band's Dixie Chicks remember Dixie
Chicks they were somewhat relevant 20
years ago I think that was the last time
too that they were somewhere relevant
well they're back kind of they're not
back with any music in particular than
anyone's talking about they're back
changing their names the Dixie Chicks
have taken out Dixie because we've got
to cancel the south so the Dixie Chicks
are just the chicks
which to me is still pretty offensive
dot chicks they're the only chicks there
erasing the lived experience of all the
other chicks they've just got to be
chicks but if their chicks don't you
think that's a little sexist they're
gonna be broads dames I don't think so
you think chicks is just referring to
birds what about all the other birds huh
what about the Eagles speaking of which
probably got to cancel the Eagles so the
Dixie Chicks they're out and Lady
Antebellum a musician that I've never
heard of has changed her name to Lady a
which is taken by somebody else you
didn't look into that's that's a big
issue
lady yeah because you can't be
Antebellum that's pre-war maybe she
could be lady reconstruction which is
what happened after the Civil War but if
she's lady reconstruction let's not
forget it reconstruction is what led to
many of the horrors that followed from
the Civil War Jim Crow segregation
lynchings all that kind of she can't be
that can she be a lady well what's a
lady who's who the heck are you to
define to me what a lady is a man can be
a lady thank you very much there's no
end to that when you start tearing down
the statues you are left with nothing
when you start tearing down the names
because one word is offensive ultimately
there's nothing you can say there's no
limiting principle to what the left is
saying in my hometown in the town of my
birth Mount Kisco New York there's a
statue of Christopher Columbus they want
to tear it down there's a there's a
petition going around I think 750 or 800
people have signed it they want to get
it to a thousand it's relatively small
town and they say in it we are a diverse
town Mount Kisco is a diverse town
populated with about ten thousand seven
hundred people it is appalling to see a
Christopher Columbus statue in this town
then they list all of the crimes that he
didn't commit but they think he
committed Christopher Columbus is a
tyrant which is why we need to take down
his statue in no way does Mount Kisco
represent the atrocities committed by
Columbus so why should there be a statue
in our town in his honor what they mean
by diverse is that increasingly over the
last 20 years or so particularly because
of immigration policies the town has
become largely Hispanic there are a lot
more Hispanic people in town I strongly
suspect by the way that this petition is
being pushed by white liberals
because I don't think recent immigrants
have very much - time to care about
these frivolous types of things these
political agitations but they're doing
it at least in the name of diversity
referring to the Hispanic population
apparently unaware that Hispanic people
would not exist without Christopher
Columbus Christopher Columbus invented
Latinos so I've mentioned this in
speeches before some people tell me it's
offensive how is it offensive it's
simply true what is Hispanic or Latino
it's the combination of Spaniards with
indigenous populations specifically in
Latin America that would not exist if
the Spaniards hadn't come to America and
who brought the Spaniards to America was
Christopher Columbus so if you like
diversity in Hispanics and Latinos you
have a Latino friend you ought to
support Columbus because he's the reason
that Latinos exist but they don't want
diversity that's not what this is this
is not what this is about people have to
cut it out with dye well I support BLM
because I think black lives matter BLM
has nothing to do with black lives
matter well I support these tearing down
the statues because I support diversity
has nothing to do with diversity this is
about a specific plan a specific
ideological strategy and political
strategy to tear down our nation and our
culture and our civilization we talked
last week about how black lives matter
is a Marxist organization one of the
founders patrisse cullors
admitted on film she said we are trained
Marxists we who founded BLM well another
one of the founders because in that case
she was referring to Patrice was
referring to herself and Alicia Garza
another another founder as trained
Marxists but the third founder whose
name is opal tometi recently surfaced in
a photo with the communist dictator of
venezuela nicolas maduro she's smiling
she's got her hand up she's so excited
to be with Maduro black lives matter and
the associated movements the black lives
matter in particular is a Marxist
organization they say they're a Marxist
organization their founders are admitted
avowed Marxists and trained Marxists
there are website talks in Marxist
language about doing Marxist
if you support black lives matter you
are supporting Marxism how did how did
Marxism get a hold in 2020 of all places
thirty years after the fall of the
Berlin Wall
that might have something to do with
liberalism and the weaknesses of
liberalism we can talk about that as
well but there there is a plan here
there is a strategy there is an ideology
we should say its name we should not be
cowed into silence we should not be
cowed into apathy we should not be we
should not make the opposite you know
the the equal and opposite reaction of
of Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer at the
top of the show who pretend that they're
they care about saying somebody's name
George Floyd they don't really they're
pushing their ideological agenda we
should be able to call out that specific
ideological agenda while a specific
ideology is tearing down statues in this
country tearing down our whole culture
if we can't even name that ideology we
can't even name those activists then
we're certainly not going to be able to
stop it and then we'll all be sitting
around the rubble saying oh gosh didn't
we used to have a great country didn't
we used to have a great culture oh well
too bad
2020 can't get worse 2020 could get a
lot better but we're going to have to
step up and take action I'm Michael
Knoll since the Michael Nolt show I'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders
hair and makeup
nikka geneva production assistant ryan
love the michael knowles show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton
[Music]